[Music]
hi welcome to the making life changes
urban gardening channel my name is
harold helm and i'm out here today to
give you some great gardening tips
on how you can have continual sea of
green
when it comes to harvesting your green
leafy vegetables some people like to
come out here and just pull your
vegetables up
the whole plant and then you got to
plant new seeds now that works great if
you have lots of land
but if you're like us and you live in
the city or suburb or you have
just a small area where you're doing
what we call square foot
urban gardening you're going to be a
little bit more
surgically precise when it comes to
harvesting so you can continue to reap
harvesters week after week after week
and so today we have several types of
plants here this is a siberian kale
beautiful you see how large it is the
leaf's very healthy
we also have dinosaur kale and then we
have
red leaf lettuce and we have some
spinach that we're going to be
harvesting as well and so today what
we're going to do
is we're going to harvest just the
leaves that we want to take off the
plant
we're going to leave enough leaf and
foliage on the plant so the plant will
grow back if you do this
every two to three weeks you can come
out here and harvest and you can
continue to have a perpetual sea
of green and you're going to get so much
greens that you won't be able to eat at
all so you're going to have to learn how
to freeze it preserve it maybe
you can it there's a lot of interesting
ways that you can do it so what we do is
we just go around the plant i'm going to
look for the big leafs the leaves that i
know
that i need to go ahead and take off and
give me a good pair of scissors or some
shears
you want to go right down here to the
base you can see this the base of the
plant
and i'm just going to cut right there at
the bottom take this whole leaf off just
like this
i'm going to collect it later i'm going
to clean these i've got a great video
shows you how to clean these leaves and
get everything off and get them ready so
i'm just going to go around the plant
and i'm going to take off all these
bottom leaves
even some of these don't look real great
because we want to remove them from the
plant anyway
because it's going to encourage new
growth
and just work your way around the plant
don't take the little leaves off because
you want something to grow back
you can have some of these leaves that
are going to be a little yellow these
are leaves you can throw into your
compost bin and recycle them they're no
good
but you want to get them off the plant
to encourage new growth
so i'm going to go around here and take
these off
and this one here i can take off too
it's pretty good
size
and there you go and actually i can take
this one other one off it's kind of
medium i could have left it on but i'm
going to go ahead and pull it
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
encourage i'm going to leave three four
leads on
and i'm going to encourage new growth in
just two to three weeks the plant's
going to be that same size
and it'll be time to harvest again and
you can do the same thing with all your
different green leafy vegetables
with this dinosaur kale dinosaur kale
doesn't quite get as big
it's okay they're going to be smaller
these are really tasty especially if you
put them in
a recipe like some white beans and rice
and cook them in kale is just wonderful
it's rich and all kind of vitamins
especially vitamin a
high in fiber very nutritious and it's a
super food
and there's one leaf down here that's
kind of going bad a little bit
starting to get the yellow you just
throw that into the compost bin so i'm
going to take this
kale and clip it all the way off
so i'm going to work it all the way to
the top of the plant
until i get to the small leaves once i
get to the small leaves
i am not going to mess with the small
leaves i'm going to leave the very very
small leaves
on the plant to encourage new growth so
the new leaves can grow back
so i'm going to leave that on there all
this is it's going to grow back and
continue to get up
and this kale will continue to grow
taller and taller and eventually will go
through its lifespan
now red leafy vegetables green leaf
vegetables whatever type of lettuce you
like it's the exact same thing
you just work your way around the bottom
of the plant
and you really got to get in here it's
good to kind of leave yourself some
space when you're working in your garden
that's why we put one plant per square
foot so you can get in your garden
without stepping on your plants and
they're not too overcrowded
i definitely want to remove this bad
leaves down here
and throw them into the compost bin get
all that out because it will encourage
new growth then you just want to go
around your plant
and this is one plant all these plants
that were taken from today they actually
survived
the winter storm down here in the
houston area down here in texas
and we were very fortunate we covered
our plants
these are green hearty uh winter
tolerant plants and so they survived we
did lose a few plants
but most of the plants survived and this
is what's left and look they're grown
back
and we're getting amazing harvesters
from them
so we're going to continue to work
around the plant
and take off all these green leaves
and don't take them all off you want to
leave some so they grow back
and i'll show you what it looks like
when we get through
these are great for sandwiches salads
and grow really fast so you want to come
out here you want to trim them but if
you don't take the whole plant up
they'll grow back
that's the beautiful thing about it so
there's one more leaf on the side i'll
take this one
and you just want to look to see how big
they are see this one these are small
these are small i'm going to leave them
this is small this is still growing
there's one back over here i'll take and
this one right here and that's it
and i'm going to leave that on there and
it's going to grow back and a couple
weeks it's going to be another big plant
again
so i have a perpetual sea of green
constantly harvesting from my garden
and one thing you want to do too when
you take your plants in and you clean
them up and you take the stems out make
sure that before you use them
that you soak them in some water about a
gallon half gallon of water fill your
bowl up
and put you about a capful of vinegar
regular white vinegar and let it set for
15-20 minutes at least that'll kill all
the germs that are on the plant so if
there's any bacteria
on the plant they're not contaminated
let me show you the spinach
now you can see we're filling this bowl
up we're gonna come back out here we're
gonna get
several more bowls of these filled up
here as we harvest
and we're going to have to end up
freezing a lot of our kale not the
lettuce but the kale freezes very well
and so we'll put it in storage bags and
put it in the freezer
and continue to have kale throughout the
the year and same with spinach get in
here so you can see this
here's the spinach plant some people
just go and they pull this whole plant
up but then you kill the plant
so what we're going to do is we're going
to clip just right around the outside
edge and take all these big leaves off
and by doing this we're encouraging new
growth
and we're reusing the same plant we're
not having to wait
a long time
for these plants to produce a new
spinach plant
we're going to continue to clean
everything up and take all the leaves
off
and eventually we're going to be left
with just some plants that
have a few leaves on them in a few weeks
they're going to grow back and we're
going to have
more great greens it's going to be a
perpetual sea of harvest protection sea
of green
and this is what we're doing here at
making life changes if we've helped you
today
in this video please uh give us a like
and subscribe if you haven't already hit
that bell so you don't miss any of our
updates
and share our videos on social media i
am making life changes you can too
god bless you
you